one group gets popcorn the other dozens
but this isn't an ordinary night out of
the cinema it's a scientific study the
question under investigation is whether
chewing can have an effect on memory
retention Sasha top alinsky a
psychologist at the University of
Cologne says it can his theory eating
popcorn makes it less likely you'll
remember the advertisements that's
because we're more likely to retain the
names of new products when our mouths
aren't otherwise occupied yet steam key
here in the cinema we give our research
subjects popcorn [ __ ] that way they
won't unconsciously repeat the names of
the products after one week we see how
much the test subjects who had popcorn
remember about the advertising gabba
thick tag a sensor on the skin shows
whether the test subject recognizes the
name of the product the result the
popcorn eaters show very little response
to the advertised products but the group
that wasn't munching through the ads
demonstrates a strong response either
studio tagged the study shows that when
you keep your mouth busy eating popcorn
you'll have a very poor memory for brand
names so your body plays an important
role in this particular process when it
comes to remembering names it's your
mouth that makes all the difference the
findings are confirmed when the test
subjects go shopping only the people who
weren't distracted by popcorn show any
interest in the advertised products you
know you will see in effect on shopping
behavior we see an advertising effect on
the test subjects who didn't eat the
popcorn who are more likely to buy the
product that's not the case for the
popcorn eaters
the body has its own memory for
experiences and impressions top alinsky
believes the body is the basis of
understanding and memory an art as well
as advertising the brain processes the
input it receives by recreating it but
when the body is also involved he says
emotional response can be strengthened
yeah me neither in one study we had our
test subjects look at a painting and
encourage them to make hand movements
while doing it when that hand movement
mirrored the motion the artist made
while painting the test subjects like to
painting more than they would have
otherwise Mia it's a new approach to
psychology the idea of embodiment top
alinsky looks at how abstract messages
are communicated and comprehended
through movements of the body during
conversations for example the popcorn
test is just one piece of evidence easy
if you had like this experiment and many
others show that the body plays a very
important role in the formation of
memories and in how we perceive and
understand experiences but top alinsky
says the advertising industry still
hasn't shown much interest in his
research based on his findings the ad
industry might want to try to ban
popcorn in the cinema entirely but a
movie without munchies would prove a
pretty unpopular step
Oh